we're live I think we are live I hope we
are live are we live I got a thumbs up
we are live okay guys uh this is gonna
be a bit of a crazy night obviously for
the country uh also for us on this live
stream right here so first off we are at
the Tampa Convention Center here at
DeSantis campaign headquarter Victory
party Freedom loving Florida Freedom the
whole thing is all happening right here
at the Tampa Convention Center we had a
studio set up in an alternate room with
beautiful lighting we're gonna do our
whole thing in there and then at the
last minute we were like wait wait wait
we need to be in the room so it's gonna
be loud okay I'm telling you right now
we're doing some of this on the Fly uh I
think you can tell by the lighting bit
of a party atmosphere in here they've
got the fox feed running there's
literally thousands of people here it's
the convention center so it's absolutely
massive you can tell the feeling here is
really fantastic like people are just
psyched there's just such a feeling of
that regardless of what happens in the
throughout the country tonight although
everyone's feeling pretty good about
that that it just has been done right
here and it's a real celebration of the
guy who's going to be coming on stage in
about a half hour from now obviously
Governor Ron DeSantis some early numbers
are trickling in I've got an iPad that
is connected to the internet so my guys
can give me some numbers on the Fly I'm
sure many of you are watching probably
on a computer or a phone or an iPad you
got a TV on sounds like something good
is being reported on Fox right at the
moment uh but yeah there's there's a
real feeling that this that this wave is
gonna happen you don't want to count the
chickens before they hatch but I'm I'm
just super psyched to be here in Florida
and doing this so bear with us if we
have some technical stuff up
and uh and some audio stuff uh the
lieutenant governor of Florida Jeanette
Nunez is going to join us in a few
minutes also Congressman Byron Donald
who is the congressman from the Fort
Myers Naples Sanibel area dealing with
all this hurricane Ian craziness he's
going to join us Fox News is Lisa Booth
is going to join us Carol Marco it's
from the New York Post is going to join
us John cardillo is going to join us we
are going to try to get the governor
that is the plan after he speaks but as
I think you'll probably hear the guy is
pretty much lost his voice he has been
out there despite all the polling and
all the energy and all the numbers he's
been out there alongside Casey DeSantis
the first lady and they have been
campaigning busting their butts uh so
his voice is going a little bit but
hopefully we'll get him but it's a
serious celebration here one of the many
bars is about 10 feet away so I will
probably bust out some tequila once we
get the official numbers from far data
and I think we have the lieutenant
governor coming in in just a couple
minutes and we're just really doing this
on the Fly Guys and we appreciate you
watching whether you're on uh rumble or
locals or on YouTube right now I voted
this morning and uh I think we've got
the lieutenant governor right now we're
going to get her miked up real quick and
then we're just gonna jump right into it
uh yeah we can get you on in there we're
doing this all on the Fly we're going to
get you miked up Lieutenant Governor
Jeanette Nunez we'll give her just a
minute to get settled don't worry the
camera won't be on you just yet
um there is such a good feeling here in
Florida guys I got to tell you for those
of you that live in Florida you get it
for those of you that just watch my
shows or whatever it might be you're
just reading about what's going on here
in Florida they're they're really it's
just a uh there is a Renaissance of
Freedom how you feel and we're ready to
roll are you Mike are you oh you're not
miked up she's not miked up I told you
guys we're doing this on the flight
let's get the uh Lieutenant Governor
Mike people walking across the camera
when I tell you guys
as I said we had a studio over there we
wanted to be a nice party atmosphere so
we're we're just going for it tonight
this is called live production there you
go walking under the camera
um from what I'm hearing let's just
quickly as I wait for the lieutenant
governor to check in here
right now we're seeing that Governor
DeSantis is up eight points in
Miami-Dade County which is absolutely
massive uh with 60 in he lost Miami-Dade
by 20 points back in 2018 so it's worth
noting that not only are the numbers
changing but as I said several times on
the show last couple weeks
Governor DeSantis Congressman at the
time is a scientists only won in 2018
that's only four short years ago the
only one Florida by about 30 000 votes
so something really remarkable has
happened here in Florida and I really
believe it is the blueprint that has to
be mapped across all of the country a
couple other things that are rolling in
at the moment is that a republican
governor of Ohio Mike deween is expected
to win his re-election according to Fox
News and as I said Fox is going right
behind us so we're just going to do this
all on the Fly you guys can I throw it
in the lieutenant governor all right
I told the guys that I just told my
audience we had a nice studio in a side
room ready to go it's going to be nice
and quiet and at the last minute I
forced everybody right here
what do you make of what is going on
here tonight and broadly in Florida well
I mean I think is the beginning of a
movement right it is a movement that
recognizes what we've done with Governor
DeSantis is done in Florida protecting
people's Liberties making sure that kids
could get a quality Education Without
indoctrination protecting parents right
making sure that people can live their
lives open their businesses run their
businesses have employees come to work
and what you're seeing here is the
culmination of a tremendous amount of
enthusiasm new Floridians Floridians you
know people that have lived here all
their lives Seventh Generation
Floridians and everyone realizes that
what we've done here is probably nothing
short of historic do we new Floridians
owed OG Floridians anything I mean I
know we owe you guys you did it right we
owe you something do you want cash what
are you doing
which is what I thought we got it for
America everyone that I brought you got
it from everybody there you go talk a
little bit about what it was like at the
height when the governor really you know
people forget now like as if everything
was open the whole time and everything
else but when the governor really was
going against going against the CDC
fighting to keep everything open you
along beside him obviously what kind of
they were criticizing us they were
saying that we were going to be you know
the worst thing that Florida was going
to be you know the the kiss of death and
so you know the governor stayed before
he didn't clinch he did not pay to the
pressures that came from all over and
and I think that that's a testament to
his leadership style his courage and
then I think people recognize a leader
when they see him someone that's willing
to make tough decisions because they
were difficult decisions let's not get
ourselves not a lot was known as the
time a lot of fear a lot of panic a lot
of it driven by the media but he made
those difficult decisions he stood firm
and he realized that he was doing what
was in the best interest of Floridians
and if that was going to cost him his
jobs they'll be it but I think that
they're putting here what we're seeing
again the amount of people that have
moved to Florida the amount of people
that can come to us
job because of you I want to keep my
family business because of you my child
was able to get an education because of
you that is above any one individual
that's above any one particular race so
that's why I always say freedom was on
the balance at the time do you think he
was he was fully uh trained for this or
did he grow into it because again it now
seems easy to look back and be like oh
he did the right stuff but but sometimes
people actually it happens to them on
the Fly and since you know him in a more
intimate way than everyone watches so
what I would say is that leadership
trades are always there right so courage
bravery commitment principle not someone
that's going to waver it's gonna you
know take a committee and do a poll on
every single decision and I think that
that's always intrinsically who he is
um but of course you have to learn on
the Fly you have to fit through data you
have to trust your energy you have to
again be willing to make difficult
decisions that may not be popular but
when things settle when the dust settled
we saw all the different cooking Parts
is related to covid and beyond that
obviously hurricanes and and other
things other crises we've had to do with
building collapses
his convictions and principles really
led the way and that made it easy for
him to sort of adjust to whatever
I got one more for you because I'm sure
you want to get out there with all the
people as well uh going on the
assumption that tonight works out and I
sense that we're uh pretty much okay
saying that here what what do you guys
have planned for the next in the next
couple of years I mean things are going
pretty well I think they are going well
and we want to make sure that they
continue to go well so a lot that we
still have to tackle a lot on education
a lot on the environment I think the
governor has already talked a lot about
combating some of that corporate
wokeness like ESG and continuing down
that path because we see what's
happening
um clearly uh we want to tackle some of
the issues of the day that impact
Floridians from every Walk of Life
Property Insurance you know we'll be
working on a special session to address
some of those issues and then you know
who knows what the next four years has
in store for us I'm sure it'll be
interesting it's always fun it's always
uh you know a lot of energy and he's
someone that again energy is the
executive and a lot of decisiveness
you're going to get out of here well
Lieutenant Governors I thank you for
your service and it's an exciting night
get out there as well thank you are you
drinking with the people
[Music]
a little early for the drinks very much
uh all right well I think that's uh
you're you're good you are you are
totally free
um I think that's just a little taste of
what's going on here in Florida right
it's not about what the government can
give you it's not about what these
people are going to really do for you
it's about how can we create the
conditions to keep you free and that is
our plan that is that is their plan and
I would say it's our plan as anyone
that's here that is a free Floridian who
are we gonna get we're going to get
Carol Marco it's New York posts Carol
Marco it's uh is going to join us in
just a moment Carol wrote doing this on
the Fly lady we're gonna mic you up
Carol for those of you that do not know
although many of you do from the show
Carol is also a new Floridian transplant
from Brooklyn Carol I think if I'm not
mistaken you moved like literally the
same week that I ride around the same
time I got here on December 17th oh so I
was like two weeks later two weeks later
yeah but you were very powerful
existence over here uh well I guess I'll
ask you something unrelated to Florida
for a second but since you have left New
York you were you were a brooklynite you
left New York I was I was born in
Brooklyn grew up in Long Island lived in
New York City most of my life uh what do
you think's gonna happen in New York
tonight so it's the one that I want the
most so it's hard to be clear-headed
about it I really want to leave Delton
to win it's funny because a lot of
people think because I laughed I want
New York to fail or I wanted to collapse
I wanted to come back I don't need to be
there for it to come back I just wanted
to succeed
I think lizelle then it'll be such a
good first step
in my hard part I'm trying not to like
get too wrapped up in it because I don't
think it happens but if it does that'll
be such a pleasant surprise I don't
think it'll happen it's so tough New
York it's just New York City is so hard
to overcome even if he gets a lot of
Upstate in Long Island it's interesting
I'm trying not to give people false hope
but look if he wins we're all so happy
and it's you know but what a great
turnout you know
whether it's Baltimore
oh God
you're literally the only person that's
the worst movie
yeah I hate Shawshank Redemption movie
about Freedom you borrowed out that's
moving so bad and crap to get to Florida
all right so you moved to Florida things
obviously have have been great here yeah
I mean [ __ ] be bad right
so people ask me like I miss my family
um Halloween was like you know different
it wasn't quite what it wasn't Frozen
it was good it just wasn't Brooklyn
Halloween is sort of an amazing thing
um but I really don't miss anything I
don't like I don't feel longing for New
York like I thought I would and I love
it here so much I wake up happy and calm
all the time yeah is that what it is I
mean I've asked you this I'm sure a
couple times and we talk about it
probably not but it's that any more than
anything else it's not all the political
stuff necessarily although that's
annoying yeah that's what I try and
explain to you there's a spirit of
Freedom here that makes people happier
right and more joyous it's what our
default position should it should be
right this erotic anger that so many
people are walking around but it helps
that I don't have to worry about my kids
in school it's a big thing so I don't
know whether
you think that the rest of the night
this looks pretty solid I think things
look really good
I would say that the one that I'm most
worried about is probably Georgia
um I just don't have a lot of faith in
their elections yeah and I what do we do
about that I mean you're an actual
journalist so I don't have to go like
this
I really don't know it's very tough I
mean just hearing all the problems
they're having in like Arizona this
should not be the norm we don't live in
a third world country I'm the most
pro-american person and it crushes me
that we can't have good elections it
really is a problem let's look Florida
does it right like why can't they just
copy Florida you know wasn't it
refreshing today I mean when I voted
it's so good to go in with the pens yeah
actually mark it down put it in an
envelope then walk it over to oh is that
how you had oh yeah yeah I walk it over
to another person who confirms that I am
me even though that I was right there
showing ideas crazy yeah it really was
such a joy I was like oh this place is
functional right it's functioning it's
functional it's totally different than
boating in New York voting in New York
is insane I think Monica Crowley posted
that she got two ballots in New York and
like she returned hers for what if she
had it you know and then somebody voted
twice
um there's a lot of problems and I I
wonder if the problem is that a lot of
people don't want to solve those
problems they like having those issues
because I think they're very solid
a rocket science isn't it weird in a way
it's almost like the default position he
said nothing works don't work right it's
like oh right sure elections always used
to be done at midnight but now they're
in three week Adventures if you're like
oh well that's how it is now right
that's just the thing that we do now but
Florida's so interesting because they
had some election trouble and then they
decided like no we're gonna fix this and
then they fixed it and it's just living
in a state where that happens is so
magical and you know encouraging we
really should both have side gigs as
real estate
would you like to make any other
predictions or commentary on this
channel they're giving me the signal
um I don't know I think it's gonna be a
real tsunami a red tsunami I think Miami
Dade going red and that sounds very
plausible I think maybe Palm Beach
County goes red which would be insane
but you know maybe
um I don't know Governor by by at least
seven maybe by 10. 7 10. I'm saying
I think I said to him when we did the
Orlando show I was backstage with him
just the two of us this was back in June
and I said Governor I think I neither
said 14 or 15 years to win by 14. he
laughed in my face so I wanted to I
wanted to be just for the story to work
out okay
have a drink
I'm gonna keep yelling at the camera for
a while all right thank you all right
who do we have next things
we have Byron Donald's Congressman Byron
Donalds is going to come in a few
minutes I'm actually thrilled he's here
you know so Congressman Byron Donald
who's the congressman from Southwest
Florida that's Fort Myers Naples Sanibel
Captiva area obviously hurricane Ian
just completely decimated the area even
coming here today
we drove across Florida when you drive
through Southwest Florida 75 it's known
as Alligator Alley because you're
basically on one road you got like a
long moat Everglades on the side and
you're seeing alligators and birds and
whatever but as we got to towards
Southwest Florida the further west we
came started seeing more of the
destruction and just old awesome trees
that were toppled over and roofs that
are ripped off and all sorts of stuff
but but Florida is rebuilding so
incredibly fast uh it's really
remarkable so the congressman is on his
way in just a minute I'll give you some
numbers I'm sure you guys are watching
on on many screens at this point uh
right now is 63 percent in here in
Florida and we'll try to widen out of
Florida I get I get a very Florida
focused right now uh we have Marco Rubio
a little over 54 Val demings about 44 so
that's looking good DeSantis up by 13
points right now
56-43 for Charlie Chris 13 points I want
DeSantis at 14 15 points uh and with 16
in in Georgia which is a very low number
obviously uh Rafael Warnock 56 at
Herschel Walker at 43 but that that's
very early so we'll see about that but
let's take it back to Florida right now
Congressman Byron Donalds good to see
you man man it's good to be with you I
uh I'm glad to be talking to you let's
let's do some of the hard lifting first
and then we'll talk about what's going
on here tonight so how is southwest
Florida what should people know as I was
just telling people driving across
Alligator Alley today it was the first
time I saw some of the destruction and
trees down and everything what's the
latest what are you doing how can we
help the latest right now with
Mario Islands they're in pretty bad
shape
[Music]
the governor just did the right thing
cut the right thing because the British
accent how did you guys how did you do
it so quickly I mean not Sanibel
Causeway it was busted in 10 different
areas it's a huge Bridge how did how did
it happen
when it comes to actually doing the work
yeah all the different things you got to
do that's what takes the time so when
you're committed to just triaging the
situation and getting it done is pretty
simple work we had contractors who said
you could do it in about four weeks if
you can get through all the red tape and
all the bureaucracy
and you did it you did it but it's
basically it lasted four weeks how can
people help at this point right now
[Music]
that's a huge
.org we're going to be using to try to
help people who have just damage or
maybe they didn't have insurance
to try to find ways to help them build
back other than that and a spirit of
people in Southwest Florida is really
really strong yeah they want to get back
they want to rebuild that's a positive
thing what's the event on December 1st
I'm going to try to get there isn't
there a big connection
Arena we're going to have Leonard
Skinner Ted Nugent many other acts are
going to be there all going to support
people in Southwest Florida help them
rebuild from Hurricane in all right cool
I'm going to try to come to that now
let's talk about what's going on here
tonight I was telling my audience we had
a nice quiet studio in another room over
there and then at the last second I was
like we got to get in this room no
matter how loud it is I don't know if
anyone can hear Russian there or they're
just hearing fox in the background uh
there is something incredible going on
in Florida uh are you are you born and
bred Floridian no I'm a New Yorker
you're a New Yorker New York born and
raised I'm born in Brooklyn in
Bensonhurst yeah so all right so how
long you been here
I made the right decision I stayed in
Florida and the rest is going from there
so what what is happening here in these
last couple years do you remember a
moment that it started that now Florida
is the blueprint of Freedom not only for
the country but I think for the whole
world well it's a couple of things first
and foremost we've had consistent
governance by conservatives in the state
legislature in the governor's mansion
but then what really changed it honestly
was covet 19. when covet hit it
demonstrated clearly to everybody who
was for freedom and who was for just
controlling every aspects of your life
all of the political arguments we had in
the past came to reality and people saw
it firsthand so you had a lot of people
leave their states and come to Florida
fortunately for us we had a governor who
was committed to the freedom of the
people of Florida and now the results of
election night are the fruits of all of
that yeah and you're saying that before
we got the results so you're feeling
pretty listen man I can tell you I know
this state I've seen the state been
through it talk to the people and it's
not just in Florida there's people all
across the country there are people in
other states who wanted to get to
Florida they didn't have escape velocity
they had something that was still
keeping them in their state they wanted
to be here but they couldn't but then
the new people who come when you talk to
them they're like man I should have came
here a lot sooner this what was going on
in my home state was terrible but I'm
glad I'm in Florida because I just want
to go to the beach I want to go to a
restaurant I just want to hang out with
my friends and not be bothered not be
persecuted because I want to live my
life what kind of strains has that put
on the local communities when all these
new people move in so you know I'm in
the Miami area obviously real estate is
crazy right now because you know 300 000
new people come into Florida it
increases the housing so that's one
thing what other stresses are there what
can what can all the new people that are
appreciative what can we do that's what
I just asked the lieutenant governor how
can we help more listen I want the ogs
to feel appreciated it's about real
estate and Rose it's gonna be tough
because we brought so many people into
the State this is why I tried to explain
to Joe Biden and those guys when you
have a lack of products but everybody's
got money the prices go up well in
Florida we didn't have an economics
divided I got to do my job man that's
the people tell me to do yeah but listen
when you have a limited amount of
housing which I mean if Florida we have
housing stock issues because people keep
moving here but when you have so many
people come and then they have the money
to spend the prices go up secondarily
roads the roads were built for an
estimate of x amount of people why
showed up because the Democrats don't
know what they're doing in the blue
States so it was a good problem to have
overall now where we are you kind of get
an opportunity for that to settle in
we're going to open the build more
houses stuff like that hopefully at the
federal level we get our economy back on
track and we get inflation under control
so your home builders your electricians
your roofers they're not having to pay
through the nodes for their materials
but sinfuls on the back of the people
who actually buy the homes
Byron I want you to get out there and
party with the people I thank you for
your time we'll do this again I'm going
to try to come to the event on the first
anytime thank you that's a lot all right
Congressman Byron Donalds and we're just
gonna keep we're just gonna keep rolling
through should we grab Liz wheeler all
right Congressman you're you are free to
go you are free to do your thing we're
going to grab Liz wheeler in just a
second as you can see a little little
chaos this live man it's live it's got I
tell you one thing it's more real than
what's going on on MSNBC or CNN has the
crying begun yet I has the crying begun
on MSNBC yet are they crying on MSNBC
yet
the crying has begun so let me just see
if I got some updated numbers here the
last numbers I'm looking at here in
Florida that 56 percent the sand is 6
just beautiful
just beautiful I don't know if you guys
saw it there was a clip going viral from
CBS News I think it was earlier today
where they sent some people out and
about in Florida just trying to find
Charlie Chris supporters and they
literally could not find anybody that's
actually quite hilarious I have a uh a
non I have a non-floridian with me
that's true although you've made your
best efforts that turned me into one yes
you are a non-floridian yet Liz wheeler
of the Liz wheeler podcast and many time
Reuben report guests what what brings
you to Florida on a night like this
that's electric energy
which was incredible it's across the
whole state Miami-Dade is crazy
or by 20 points in 2018. he lost by 20
in 2018 but he's up by about 12 right I
mean that's that's crazy it's crazy
what's that the American people aren't
stupid that they don't want the wokeness
that the Democratic party offers and
that they understand that
Republicans are offering them lower gas
prices
she bills for rental control over
education and freedom instead of Cove
attorneys so one of one of the uh all
right something something good is
happening oh yeah all right so Marco
Rubio all right they just called it
there you go we're doing this on the Fly
people so they just called Marco Rubio
so officially remained the senator uh
from right here in Florida we thought
that was going to happen but it's still
nice we did but did you see margin
that's a thing
it was a margin
so so one of the reasons that I love you
Liz is you every time you come on my
show you lay out facts a lot of people
just kind of talk about stuff you lay
out facts and in some ways this election
to me it's not just here at Florida but
it seems like an election of reality
like are we going to live in non-reality
with boys and girls as boys and
everything else and everyone's racist
all right Alabama has been called I
respected that one but you must feel
pretty good that like people seem to
just they just want you know that's what
I really think this is about I think
what's happened in our country in the
last two years is that the things that
you and I have been talking about for
maybe decades has finally touched people
only had about six years that's right
you're like a baby doctor
it's finally touched people's lives and
I'm sad to say that because I don't want
critical race Theory and the transgender
ideology and inflation and rhyme to
touch people's lives but when they
realize that it's going to negatively
impact them they realize it's not
arbitrary it's happening
[Applause]
oh it's cold that was it that was it
that was it 15 points
50. I told the governor I told the
governor on June 2nd the Two of Us in
Orlando in the green room I said you're
gonna win by 15 points he laughed in my
face all right Governor DeSantis
that is awesome well all right so the
night has just been done here
the governor I'm sure is probably
drinking some tea the guy lost his voice
basically so I don't blame him yeah he's
been talking to people he's been he's
been walking the walk 15
[Music]
Republicans taking back the Senate so I
think it's going to be a Runway
is not politicians right it's us we've
been negatively impacted by dividing
Administration we have been negatively
impacted by a democrat congress and
we're all saying I don't think so it's
time for that to end
so far I didn't think they were going to
call it this early for Florida 15 points
obviously the margins can change a
little bit here or there but that's
awesome we'll be over by 12 is that
Rubio by 12 okay
I've got a couple numbers here yeah well
let me sign this for you how you doing
there you go
don't free people they
and John cardillo's jumping in there you
go my man hey a little bit different
than cable news over here it is
a little bit different a little bit
different all right
all right
Joe there's your pen you can have your
pen too
all right John cardillo is joining me
John you've been on my show a million
times yeah
wait what
I tell you
I told the Santas you told the Santa
I've been saying 15 all day
we were voting today absolutely
absolutely
that's a great day this can be a 17 to
20 point win John you're you're people
trying to bust in on us right here
you're sort of my uh I would say my
Floridian political Insider but what is
and they're also originally a New Yorker
New York we've been here about 19 years
almost 19. I get here about 19 years ago
this place has basically to become your
dream what's going on
it's us they're showing us yeah we want
a big
I mean it's just great here right
Florida is no longer a swing state
Florida is no longer an outlier we are
attached to your population state and
we're a red State now gave a solid red
State and I think Ford is the model of
the Republicans have to follow yeah what
else do you think is going to happen
tonight I mean everybody's gone you know
I have high hopes for Arizona I think we
have some great candidates in Arizona I
uh I think we're going to do we one in
Ohio Ohio
one of the biggest takeaways for me in
Florida Ron DeSantis last I spoke to the
theme won Miami-Dade County by eight
points
decades sent to Republicans won
Miami-Dade camp
thank you for any very good night across
the United States I have high hopes for
Adam black salt in Nevada and I uh I
wouldn't be surprised if we see 53-54 in
the Senate what do we have to do with
the people who got oh their chance in
USA in an hour
now we're at a WWE
now I'm just going to body slam yeah
we'll end this thing
what do you think uh we've talked about
this a little bit privately usually over
some drinks yeah but what do you think
we have to do about all of the people
that have gotten everything wrong not
just the ones who got everything wrong
but who actively were trampling our
friends the Atlantic did the baby yeah
yeah yeah I hope tonight is the
beginning of the demise of traditional
pollsters and I got to tell you
something what really pissed me off was
GOP chairwoman Ronald McDaniel saying oh
now Republicans are going to win big
they've got to make peace they've got to
work with Democrats hell no we've got to
crush them make them feel pain there
will be no amnesty no amnesty they need
to be held to account I want to see
people Dave I want to see them
prosecuted for what they did to
Americans knowing they were pushing
products profiteering and doing it on
junk data and that's not hyperbole
that's that Sensational lives were
destroyed people died alone weren't
allowed to go to funerals I think people
need to be able to account
investigations need to happen in
Congress people need to be slots
included don't block them out of their
houses
yeah there's there's Ben Dominic it does
I think he's a roommate reports yes too
and we're over there somewhere uh yeah
this is just so exciting I'm fired up
look I don't want just weaponization of
our side I won't Revenge
retribution and revenge as I said people
this is not what you're getting on
traditional cable news tonight so let me
let me ask about the one other place
since we both come from New York I mean
do you think zeldin has a chance I
really believe it I really oh I I would
not wake up tomorrow morning I hope so I
likely I know Z is a great guy Lee he's
a great guy I wouldn't be surprised if
he did win he's got the ability to win
by one to one point five it'll be slim
but he can do it he can do it he's got
support and he's got an infrastructure
John you got to Florida you settled the
land before me I appreciate it you're a
wired Earth damn
enjoy the rest of the night my man all
right guys good things are happening I
mean how awesome 15 points I think the
Santa shows me a drink I said 15 points
he laughed in my face we shall see all
right I think we've got a couple other
people that may join us at different
points the governor do we know when the
governor is going to be talking yet we
don't we don't know exactly when the
governor is going to jump in uh but what
we're going to try to do I think we're
going to keep the live stream going
until the governor jumps on when he
jumps on I'm just going to get out of
the way all of the mainstream media is
uh is right behind us over there so
they're going to give you the
traditional view obviously of the
governor's speech we thought it would be
fun since we did this all on the Fly and
we left the studio and we just camped
out here basically and we're right in
the midst of this thing as I said we got
the bar two feet away from us we thought
it would be fun when the governor comes
out I'm going to get right out of the
way we're going to just shift the camera
and zoom in we'll give you a different
view than anyone is going to have
because they obviously all have the
mainstream networks and all that have
their cameras directly on the on the
stage so we'll see who comes out I think
Byron who is just here Congressman Byron
Donald I think he's going to speak
before the governor there may be one or
two other people uh let's see uh I got a
tweet here from Mike cernovich Mike's
been on the show a couple of times I
used to get in a lot of trouble for
having Mike cernovich on and he's become
actually quite a a quite an astute
political pundit I think he said I'm
reading these just on the Fly he says
Red Wave doesn't even begin to describe
what's happening the turnout doesn't
even seem possible total Destruction
occurring I don't even see how they can
get away with cheating at this point let
me mention let me talk about the
cheating the cheating situation for a
second because everyone feels everyone
regardless of what side you're on if
you're if you're a republican you kind
of felt like Trump got screwed one way
or another depending on how deep you
went into that right if you're a
Democrat right now for the last week
Hillary Clinton and MSNBC and the view
has been telling you that the
Republicans are about to cheat there's a
very noxious and I would say pernicious
idea in the system that no one's going
to trust the system it's very dangerous
and it's why I was so proud again to
vote today in such a clear concise way
here in Florida a piece of paper a pen a
private booth an envelope walking that
over to another person at the actual
receptacle where I then put it in it was
all done and it was clean and legit and
there simply was going to be no doubt
that things were going to be done on the
up and up here in Florida and that's why
I think this this election as I said to
Carol
it's about sanity and it's about
confidence
I would love actually if after this
massive destruction which I've been I've
been calling for for a long time right I
have the the Democrat Party needed and
needs I again I still don't want to get
I don't want to get ahead of myself it
still needs to be destroyed let's see
what happens for the rest of the night
it's looking good right now and
certainly that you treat not as standing
but let's say uh
that's a that's a Florida race house of
course Luna the Republican winning uh
Florida is just going to be as red as
red can be I mean to save this man if
you just do it right oh Fox's Fox is
showing the crowd
right here oh that's Leah Republican
here in Florida so things obviously are
very good here uh let's see Texas
governor right now uh Texas governor
with only 15 reporting says very very
early stuff has Beto at 15 and Abbott at
42 which probably not even worth talking
about at that point uh let's see do we
have anything else here uh we're gonna
have Rob Smith joining us in just a
second I think Lisa Luke is going to be
here
uh that's the Marco Rubio win at 14
points right now these are not normal
margins excuse me
these are not normal margins guys like
you know the way things have been over
the last couple years we get elections
you know two three four points four is
often considered a big win 14 points
yeah I mean these margins these are
these are spectacular margins and again
blue green for the United States uh
don't worry
don't worry what just happened there
they were booing Joe Biden they were
booing Joe Biden nothing bad happened
here all right are we going to grab I
think we got Lisa and uh we got some
other people on the way in just a moment
okay let's see what else
I'm being told Florida has turned blood
red it's not just red but actual uh
blood red so as I said when the governor
gets out here I'm going to get out of
the way and then Our Hope of course is
that we're going to get the governor
he's losing his voice if you heard the
governor the last couple days these guys
even though they knew we knew what was
going to happen here in Florida we have
that luxury because things have been so
good and so strong but he and Casey the
first lady they just campaigned their
butts off they were all over the state
for the last really the last two weeks
and really if you think about it you
know if you go from Hurricane Ian which
was only a month ago and that they were
out there every single day in the midst
of a campaign right and basically I had
to stop campaigning end that and then
just roll right into everything that's
going on right now the last couple weeks
and see these results it's pretty great
let's see uh right now the war not
they're showing the Warnock uh Herschel
Walker's situation in Georgia it's very
low returns right now it looks like
we're not up by about 10 but but a
little too early uh let's see I'm got a
little bit more info for you there's no
voting data yet for Arizona Senate and
Pennsylvania Senate uh as well as Nevada
Senate uh the Senate uh the sites are
all saying data will come out at 10 pm
Eastern so we'll see how long uh we go
for it tonight I hope this is my water I
think this is my water this and I think
I dropped my phone down there somewhere
a lot going on people
anyway on a personal note
I have to say how how refreshing it is
to be in a place that is uh congruent
with my beliefs you know I I moved here
so that this could happen so that maybe
I could be a little piece of this so
that the the ideas that we're working in
Florida that I was watching from 3 000
miles away in California watching all
the wrong ideas and I was watching all
the right ones here and I thought I want
to be part of that and the fact that now
I'm sitting here on an incredible night
like this that you know I've been
welcomed into the fold into into what's
going on here uh in the right way in
Florida is just so freaking awesome it
really uh it's it's a complete
validation of my life not to not to make
it about me on this night because it's
not it's about America and I got a lot
of way people waving at me and yelling
at me from the side all nice things by
the way uh let's see what else is going
on here
New Hampshire governor race the
Republican Christian noodles at 50
percent Democrat Tom Sherman 48 uh
they're showing
they're showing the Florida results now
it looks like 57 descent is 41 for Chris
16 points we're at 16 points the
governor is going to owe me a steak
dinner that's what I'm going to ask uh
but let's see okay so New Hampshire is
looking good uh Georgia governor oh this
is an interesting one
29 reporting so again this is very early
stuff uh oh we just lost it no it's got
oh no sorry I got it back it's Abrams at
52 and Kemp at 47 you know it's
interesting about Stacey Abrams because
she was an election denier who ran for
governor last time obviously did not
accept the results but nobody who really
called her out in the mainstream as you
know I always say that is because of
what Democrat privilege that you can lie
and cheat and get everything wrong and
Destroy things but you fail your way up
but uh it's sort of interesting because
in the last couple weeks the media
really shifted off the Georgia
gubernatorial race which kind of makes
you think that it is not going to go
well for the Democrats but credit where
credit's due with about 30 percent in uh
Abrams does have a little bit of a lead
over there uh let's see what else is
going on over here
well we'll get some more numbers for you
in a little bit but really guys
what I think is happening Stephanie my
phone is down there somewhere
don't mind her different different live
streams there you go thank you
um
what really is happening here look it's
the sanity thing I talk about it's the
competency thing but you know six seven
years ago guys you could go back into
some of the videos that I was doing as a
disaffected liberal as a lifelong
Democrat as a two-time Obama voter and
saying Democrats there's something wrong
here this woke thing is out of control
uh we are not acting liberally you guys
know the drill on all of that and I just
kept saying it over and over and the New
York Times said I'm head of the
alt-right and you know all the nonsense
about Jordan Peterson and the protesters
and everything else and the left just
kept going the good Democrats and there
were good Democrats some of you watching
this may consider yourself old school
Democrats but your party doesn't exist
anymore and out of the ashes maybe
something good will come but hopefully
if this evening continues the way that
it that it is looking right now and
again you don't want to do any of this
too early you don't right like I'm
excited clearly because of what's going
on here in Florida and I'm in a room of
Freedom loving people that are that are
happy tonight no matter what happens
with everything else but if if this
continues if this continues the way it
looks like it's going to continue then
the X liberals or the disgruntled
liberals the Libertarians who just want
government out of the way the
conservatives who may have different
religious beliefs all of these things
all of these groups could come together
and say well what does unite us what is
it that we all just voted for what did
we all vote against what did we all lead
from the blue States why did we come to
the red stage and the the common
denominator
it is the most fundamentally human
attribute that there is that you
watching this right now want to live
your life in a certain way and and to
organize the society we need something
called a government but our Founders did
this thing in such a beautiful way with
our constitution to limit the power of
government to give you a Bill of Rights
to enshrine these incredible protections
and and then unfortunately in the course
of 250 years the government kept coming
we kept we stopped realizing what makes
us free people what makes America so
special we started becoming like the
rest of the world we started becoming
like the countries that our ancestors
fled to fled from to come here but maybe
we're about to get it back maybe we're
about to get it back and we will look
back imagine guys and I really mean this
and I think about this often
running at the Santa's uh ad right now I
think about this often as a new father
of two beautiful young boys it's like
what if I can say to my kids you know in
10 years and 15 years from now right we
start talking politics and they ask me
what was that thing what was the squad
what was woke and I just tell them about
this little blip this aberration this
ridiculous time that was fueled by
algorithms and this thing and this thing
and we didn't know what we were doing
and we almost gave it all away but we
fought for it we got it back and then we
gave that great promise to the Next
Generation I think we could do it I
think it starts right here call me crazy
uh all right so they're going to start
the the speakers on stage soon so
depending on who goes on I may continue
for a little bit or get out of the way I
promise you I will get out of the way
when Governor DeSantis gets back up
there and then we're gonna we're gonna
see I mean the the guy has been talking
forever so I'm not I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna beg the guys I'm gonna today get
them on for tonight we'll see if we can
do it if not I'm sure we can do it in
the next couple weeks or whatever it
might be uh let's see
wait this is not a joke this is not a
joke I'm being told what I'm about to
read to you is not a joke and he's
telling me it's not a joke uh Joe Biden
has turned off the TV in the West Wing
according to a White House staffer
what he was watching we don't know uh
jeez wow well that really does mean that
things are looking good uh Republican
Governor Chris sununu in New Hampshire
has won re-election so that is good so
things so at the moment
as far as I can tell nothing has gone
horrifically awry yeah right we haven't
seen one of the the major states that we
thought might flips we haven't seen any
of them fall I hope I hope you guys can
hear me by the way it's getting louder
and louder here every second and I can
tell if DeSantis doesn't have a voice I
ain't gonna have much by the end of this
but the speakers are going to speak soon
uh we'll see who goes up there it's
obviously a massive uh celebration here
just everywhere I mean literally
everywhere I'm looking it's just smiling
people everywhere it's like this is good
this is good I can't imagine what's
going on in Charlie Chris Campaign
Headquarters like was it his bedroom
like what's going on over there nothing
nothing good in Charlie Chris campaign
but this so far this is really shape
enough to be a nice knife
do we have anything out of New York is
there anything coming out of New York
yet
no we're gonna look at the iPad they
gave me this iPad
they gave me the iPad for a reason here
let's see uh
uh I'm not seeing anything from New York
on here just yet
um
oh there's no there's no data from New
York yet all right so it is uh it's
about 8 30. it's all right we're just
rolling into some man think about how
early Florida could report right because
the margins were so huge 16 points for
DeSantis is absolutely incredible how
you doing how you doing how you doing uh
the margins were so huge that they could
report early uh but we'll see what
happens in New York oh they're supposed
to come in at nine o'clock Eastern I
think the governor will be speaking at
that point but obviously as I said I'm
sure you guys Happy were watching with
one of these and one of these and the
television and all that maybe that's
part maybe that's part of our modern
problem these days I I think Perhaps it
is uh okay are we gonna are we gonna
stag Lisa or anyone else or we're gonna
wait for the governor
okay uh we're we're waiting for the for
the program to start here so we're gonna
hold off on the guests for now uh I'm
down to take a couple questions if
people want to throw some questions in
we can do that as well again guys we're
doing this all on the Fly we had a very
orderly program planned for you uh but
we just felt that this was the better
way to do it and uh yeah the signs are
coming in people are psyched and you
know there's also some some other
interesting stuff some subtext to what's
going on here in Florida obviously
president Trump gave a big rally here in
Miami two days ago he clearly endorsed
Marco Rubio he endorsed Governor
DeSantis he did vote for governor
DeSantis and there's video of him saying
that today you know there is this
potential it's I think mostly immediate
creation at the moment there's this
tension between DeSantis and Trump uh
but it's like who knows what it really
is and what they're doing on the deal I
also again said this a million times I
have no idea what this anthis wants to
do in the long term but I do know that
he loves this state but the Republicans
right now there there's a bright crop
there and there really is a feeling like
man there's there's some good people
here regardless whether if we're looking
at 2024 whether it was Trump and there's
obvious great reasons for that and
there's there's some some messy reasons
that you wouldn't want it to happen
obviously there's this there's mayor
Suarez here in Miami who I think has a
great opportunity for for a much bigger
State you've got Nikki Haley you've got
maybe a Marco Rubio or a Ted Cruz it's
just a better crop that you have on the
Democrat side but what I really think
will be interesting
the takeaway from tonight again assuming
things kind of continue to shake out the
way we're looking at them is what are
the Democrats going to do if Joe Biden
has shut the TV off and I know his
bedtime is well technically his bedtime
is 8 30. so he shut the TV off just a
little bit early tonight but if there is
this massive red wait what are the
Democrats going to do they got to blame
somebody and who is that of course it's
going to be Joe Biden and you're going
to watch them jump off the ship real
quick real quick wow so they're showing
the Florida map right now I don't know
if you can see that
well really incredible I mean basically
the entire the entire map of Florida is
red right now I don't think those are
final results obviously we're not at the
end of the night yet but basically the
entire map of Florida's red so I saw two
blue blips uh what I'm seeing there
Orlando you can see that sort of upper
middle of the state and then the
Miami-Dade area uh which is southeast
Florida but the numbers are still coming
in there and they're looking really good
for for a area that DeSantis lost by 20
points last time last we heard he was up
by eight points so super interesting
things are happening here uh let's see
another good uh piece out of Florida
Corey Mills Republicans going to take
Stephanie mersby's old seat she was a
democrat in Florida's seventh
congressional district
um oh and this is also uh interesting uh
Republicans have not only defeated
Charlie Crist obviously but also flipped
his former congressional seat from Blue
to Red all right so good things are
happening uh let's see uh what do we
have here
so am I understanding this one correctly
Myra Flores is down at the moment
what's that
okay got it so Myra Flores uh this is
the young Latino woman in the Border
Town that's Texas is uh 34th District
this is a district that was Democrat run
for a hundred years okay she is now in
early voting she's down a little bit but
there's just something interesting going
on here right everyone can kind of feel
it Myra Flores she runs she wins this
special election and then what happens
the New York Times is basically calling
her the Latina the face of Latina uh
white supremacy the same kind of stuff
that they did to Larry Elder and that
also is what so much of this election is
about that the mainstream media if
you're watching this mainstream media
people it's like no more carrying water
for the Democrats maybe you're also
realizing if this Red Wave continues
that the gravy train is over I get why
you like Democrats you like Democrats
because they're the elite you like
Democrats because they like high taxes
that keeps the power structure intact
you like Democrats because generally
speaking Democrats used to be more
liberal somehow that made meant more fun
or something like that or the connection
to Hollywood and music and all that but
it's all changing it's all changing
actually all the fun all the joy all the
good music all of the creativity it's
not that it's coming out of
conservatives it's just that it's coming
out of non-woke people the Liberals did
not defend liberalism and the fox got in
the hen house and uh the hens the hens
are are putting pretty bloody bloody red
at the moment
uh all right Fox is gonna have another
update in about a minute the room is is
uh filling up as you can see I can't I
can't quite tell how many people you can
see behind me but there's just there's
just a massive amount of people here
it's really fantastic uh we're going to
take a couple of questions from the
Ruben report Community Q a again the the
program here will start any minute and
then I'm gonna I'm gonna jump out of the
way and we'll go from there uh let's see
Margot says am I alive or am I dreaming
Margo I think you're alive or we're all
in your dream right now Margo and it's
even weirder because I'm talking to you
so if this is your dream very bizarre
but something good is happening right
now but again let's not forget guys uh
2020 election when that thing was
rolling into what 11 p.m Eastern we were
all feeling very good about what was
happening at the presidential level
right Trump was leading in all those
places so you don't want to get you
don't want to get too ahead let's see
what fox is reporting right now
foreign
Arkansas Republican we knew that was
going to happen so Arkansas will remain
red uh that was that was obviously uh
not a surprise so we'll find out more
hopefully on that Texas 34th District
but Flores oh all right so Sarah
Huckabee Sanders
Sarah Huckabee Sanders former White
House Press Secretary a little better
than John Saki and Karin Jean-Pierre she
has won she is now the governor of
Arkansas that is absolutely fantastic
I've met her a few times she's a lovely
lovely lady we'll get her on the show we
tried to do it a few times I couldn't do
it because of some scheduling things but
that's a good sign for for Arkansas
and uh
yeah a couple other
couple other things a couple other
things happening
um
I'm doing a lot of talking all right you
can throw me a few more a few more
questions and then uh if the program
doesn't start we'll uh we'll let people
get out of the way wow this is
incredible so Marco Rubio senator
obviously and Governor Ron DeSantis are
currently on Pace to win Miami-Dade by
double digits and if you want a little
context for that what is happening here
in the State of Florida Hillary Clinton
won Miami-Dade in 2016. remember that
election she won it by 30 points that is
that is such a flip it's almost
impossible to understand the level and
flip if it's double digits right now
let's just say it's 10 right we'll go
with the lowest possible double digits
it's 10 for Rubio and DeSantis after
Hillary won Miami-Dade and I'm part of
Miami-Dade and all my employees are part
of Miami-Dade there is something really
really beautiful happening here in
Florida
okay uh I I'm being told that a lot of
community members are asking about
Arizona it sounds like it's uh it's a
little unfair Connor's mom lives in
Arizona you want to get her on the phone
see what we can make happen here we'll
try to get Connor's mom to report live
from Arizona uh but again we're being
told the only official results from
Arizona aren't going to come in until 10
p.m I think our stream will be done by
then depends what happens with Governor
DeSantis so we'll see
um
you know what can also happen after this
again if it continues to go well
and I have to I just don't want to get
ahead of myself we don't know what's
going to happen with Oz and fetterman uh
we still don't have those Arizona
results obviously we don't have the
Georgia results Georgia's got a
gubernatorial anesthetic campaign going
um so we still got to wait but right now
the feeling is good right now right and
what else happens after this so we get
some sanity back we get some functional
governance back and then what if what if
we really do what the founders intended
like let's say let's say the rest of the
night to disaster for for what I would
want for what you would want let's say
New York goes remains hardcore blue
Georgia goes blue Arizona like let's say
it all goes the other direction well
then what what's the worst scenario
worst case scenario is that federalism
has to has to fight for itself meaning
that the states which are supposed to be
independent experiments of democracy
will have to do it and they'll do it
very differently and Florida will just
be very different than New York is and
Texas will be very different than
Californians that's the way it's
happening already but that's also why
you know it's one of these weird things
I'm so excited to be here in Florida for
this because this is where it directly
affects my life but we shouldn't you
know in a functional Society if things
were working the way they were intended
to work it wouldn't matter to me that
much if you lived in Florida whether
Nevada was red or blue right it really
wouldn't matter that much there would
not be some level of it but not that
much and we flipped everything you know
it's ironic right why did why did the
pilgrims come to America why did the
Boston Tea Party happen why did why did
we fight to create this incredible free
country and it's all because of freedom
and it was really it was because we
wanted to escape a centralized
government right we didn't want a king
to rule over all of us especially once
we had started the new world and yet we
have this odd thing where we think the
president's exposed to rule over all of
us and that's not really the way it's
supposed to be so if the states if
tonight if everything else from this
point after goes poorly and I certainly
hope that it does not
um
we'll just be operating the way we're
supposed to operate which is that the
states will kind of do their own
different things and we will we will see
different things uh all right I'm being
told that the Georgia race right now is
tightening uh Herschel Walker's at uh
with 45 reporting is that what I'm
getting yeah so we're 40 oh no I'm okay
with 36 reporting so it's still not that
it's still not that much uh Warnock is
leading Walker by about eight points but
it's only 36 percent it's only 36 so
basically
yeah so basically from everything I'm
seeing here there's been no disasters
yeah so so far so good guys uh you know
I'll throw in a couple comments from the
locals community and then uh if the
governor doesn't get up here soon I
think we'll we'll probably end up
cutting the stream and I'm gonna get out
there and party with these people uh
they also got a pretty sweet food spread
Republicans don't mess around it's all
good out there Jesse says do you think
there will be rioting when Republicans
win the house in the Senate well Jesse
let's just
wait let's face it let's see what
happens
um but look I do honestly believe that
that using violence and occasionally uh
releasing it when it feels necessary or
prudent is one of the tools that the
Democrats have why did we have all of
those those that summer of Peace the
riots all over these blue cities when
Trump was president and then Biden
becomes president and there's no more
BLM right there's no more Arc fighting
over systemic racism antifa kind of
disappears it's like the Democrats use
these people as foot soldiers is it
coordinated uncoordinated it's a little
hard to hard to fully understand how
they do it but these are the same people
Maxine Waters you know get in their
faces AOC the point of protest is to
make people uncomfortable they've
they've instigated so much much of this
the shooting of Steve's beliefs all of
this stuff and and one of the things
we'll have to decide again as the states
maybe go in their separate ways is we're
not going to want much out of them
meeting the blue States but they're
going to want to bunch out of us uh
[Music]
wait a minute I think we made a mistake
earlier I think
Katie Vance has not won yet correct
all right so I think I think a mistake
did get across before maybe it was I
couldn't hear properly but the Ohio race
is very early on so I think I did say
that earlier and I apologize there's
obviously a lot going on here at once uh
let's see EK says uh this is a little
out of
out of what's Happening specifically
tonight I want to know how Dave keeps up
his schedule and still looks happy and
rested all the time well I can
definitely tell you in the last uh three
months since Justin and Luke I am not
interested as I used to be but
fortunately we do have a nice amount of
help and David's doing an incredible job
and uh you know I love what I do that
really is the truth how could I not love
what I'm doing right now right like this
is the coolest gig in the world like I'm
literally
sitting here in the state that I love uh
talking about stuff that I love and
fighting for the things that I believe
in
having surrounded by people that I love
not only who work with me but who are in
this audience and and being part of
something that I think is important like
that's the main thing that kind of gets
me going that really is the main thing
and and I try to I try to take that into
all of the uh all of the parts of my
life that I can and it's not to say that
at times it isn't hard or times you're
not going to believe this every now and
again someone online says saying mean to
me but you know you just you just get
past it but I think the other things are
I try to
I try to exercise every day at least a
half hour of cardio I think that really
helps I try not to bring the telephone
into the bedroom I think that really
helps
try to eat right drink a decent amount
of water
you know I just uh I've got good friends
I've got I've got a good family yeah
things are good okay so something has
flipped a little bit here but again this
is early with only 37 percent uh Brian
Kemp obviously incumbent Republican uh
has the lead at 50 Stacey Abrams at 49
and again that's one of the bizarre
races because there was you know the
media loved loved loves Stacey Abrams
and then suddenly in the last two weeks
they kind of got real quiet about her so
who knows what's going to happen there
oh I see we're testing some cameras on
the Fly that could be interesting we
might be able to get a camera to move
within the room uh the Herschel Walker
Warnock race is also tightening about
six points separate them but again it's
very very early in people are screaming
they're very happy here
um
okay and the Ohio race is just uh is
just way too early
uh all right if you want to throw me uh
a couple more questions and then I think
we don't know what time this address is
going to go so I you know there's
obviously guys I know you love me and I
appreciate it and I love you too there's
so many places uh that you can get you
know full coverage of all of this so my
Hope was that we could go until DeSantis
comes out but since they haven't even
started the program I suspect we're
probably not going to do that I might
jump on and do some live streaming from
my phone I'll certainly be in the locals
Community talking to you guys try to do
a live chat a little bit later and see
what else is going on uh let's see so
I'll just do uh we'll go for about five
more minutes and if we don't have word
on descendants I think uh I think we'll
wrap up well it's good Macy says is
David with you tonight no the two
children did not want to come to the big
election event and be in the car for
four and a half hours from Miami to
Tampa so uh David is home with both
babies I have no doubt that I have 7 000
text messages with updates about boots
and peeing and crying and maybe some
updates about the kids too nah she liked
that one she liked that one
um all right yeah we're getting these
early results in Ohio so I don't want to
get too lost in all of that
um
Tim says what are you drinking tonight I
have not drank anything yet tonight but
there's a full bar about two feet that
way there's bars throughout and it
really is a celebration here and what
was nice is it was a celebration from
the second we got the second we got to
the hotel it's just a couple of blocks
away like everyone in the hotel lobby
you could feel it people were just like
tonight's gonna go well at least here in
the Free State of Florida and how cool
to just like plant our flag and be like
we're gonna do it right here and as I
said even if it doesn't even though
things are seemingly tracking well
throughout the country even if even if
the night turns or we don't get results
or whatever like you have to find you
have to find those blips of goodness and
if you're watching this right now and
you live in uh let's say you live in
Cali and I know a lot of you especially
because I talked to you guys in the
locals Community I know a ton of you
have either left California or thinking
of leaving to California it's like by
the end of tonight as Newsom wins again
and the L and La probably sticks with
this uh with this Democrat mayor and all
the stuff it's like you have a chance to
pick up and go
and that's a beautiful thing you can't
do that in most countries in the world
because they have more centralized
governments than we have here in the
United States and that's also why the
Democrats hate our system and they're
always trying to we want to add Supreme
Court Justices we want to make DC a
state it's not because they want more
involvement in the system it's not
because they want more choice and more
freedom it's because they want less
choice they want more calcification of
the power structure over you
but there were blips there are red
beautiful blips and we're in one here in
Florida all right
all right you got any other major
updates for me otherwise uh oh I think
we got something we got something out of
Michigan
we got something out of Michigan
uh Michigan with all right it's not even
worth reporting Michigan with five
percent reporting has Whitmer with a
significant lead 58 to 40 but that 5
reporting is literally nothing so let's
not worry about that uh and there is no
election data for the LA Mayoral race
either obviously uh West Coast is three
hours earlier so it's only uh what it's
only about uh 5 44 on the uh on the west
coast right now so you know what guys I
think we're gonna do I think we're gonna
do this I think we're gonna uh
Governor speaking in 10. the governor is
speaking in 10 minutes that means Dave
you're going to talk for 10 more minutes
all right all right
we're going to keep it going because I
do think it'll be kind of cool if we can
give you guys the live stream from this
angle it'll be totally different than
anything else that you'll see on network
news we're the only outfit here that's
not you know the official stuff right
like we're yeah
what's going on uh
so they're giving foxes giving a quick
update uh obviously Republicans having a
nice night uh in the Congress
Republicans uh
oop I could I actually couldn't see that
last part but it sounded like things are
going pretty well
isn't it fun I suppose to be watching
something that's a little bit looser and
a little bit sane and a little bit more
real than whatever the robots on CNN and
MSNBC are doing with their charts right
now all the white people live here and
white Working Class People are here and
black people are over here and it's all
just like it's so boring and gross and
they get everything wrong and they're so
lost in the numbers it's why on the show
I try to talk about ideas more than I
talk about numbers because I just think
I think ideas are what matter ideas are
what overtime
uh turn stage red and the wrong ideas I
suppose turn stays Blue are we getting
some other numbers I had an iPad
I lost my iPad
she's got my iPad okay
um can you guys even hear me at this
point I'm not even totally sure if
people can hear me you want to say hi to
people why don't you waiting for a
second that's Connor's hand everybody
you guys don't get to see that normally
during the show because he's sitting
behind the camera little he's a little
camera shy we'll see if we if Phoenix
maybe wants to wave too uh we got people
taking picture of the camera right now
sir you're using your flash he's using
his Flash
all right all right so it sounds like
Governor DeSantis is going to come out
in about eight minutes so if you can
bear with me for eight four minutes off
the cuff on the Fly can we get a couple
we'll get a couple more questions here
let me get that let me get that out of
bed
all right I'm getting some updates here
don't worry guys getting some updates
things are being copied and pasted uh as
we uh as we go right now uh by the way
uh although we are in Tampa which is
about a four and a half hour drive uh we
are going to do a show tomorrow so we're
going to get up crack of dawn tomorrow I
don't know that we can make it for the
11 A.M show that might that might be
pushing it uh but we will be doing a
live show tomorrow maybe we'll make it a
happy hour show and hopefully there'll
be plenty to celebrate I also sense that
tonight's going to be a bit of a uh of a
late night there will be plenty to
celebrate and as I said the bar is two
feet over there and I'm being told that
they do have tequila uh let's see Ryan
in the locals Community says JD Vance is
encroaching on Tim Ryan do you think
he's going to win tonight I would be
surprised if he does not look this is
one of those things where
how many times did I say on the show in
the last two weeks we all live in our
own bubble and I I am I am just like you
right I am I am a person just like you
are we all cater our needs to ourselves
I do my best to get a plurality of
voices and opinions and all of those
things I was trying to find people that
really were supporting Tim Ryan's really
getting understanding because it's clear
to me why you would vote for JD Vance if
you if you're in Ohio and you're upset
about the Fentanyl and you're upset
about what's going on with the border
and people that are moving all the way
up there and you're upset about what's
happening to the economy there like it
all makes sense
I don't know what the real argument for
Tim Ryan is but it sounds like it's
going to be a close race uh
oh it looks like Marco Rubio is giving
his acceptance speech right now that
it's somewhere else here in the Free
State of Florida and I have to say I
have to say you know I've gotten to know
Senator Rubio a little bit we've hung
out a little bit I've had him on the
show a couple of times you know he's
really a nice guy he's a he's a decent
guy I'll tell you this I don't even know
that he would fully want this to be said
but I was at a fundraiser a couple weeks
ago where there were a whole bunch of
Republicans there big time Republicans
Dr Oz was there and out of black so it
was there in JD Vance is there in Blake
Masters he's there in Senator Rubio
big major money people are there and
they were all there to give a talk and
schmooze and raise funds and everything
and as the night began Senator Rubio got
up first he said I hope you guys don't
mind if I just speak quickly and get
going but my son's football game is
tonight and he said he said you know my
son my son isn't the greatest uh but
he's he's playing tonight and I really
want to be there for that because he
doesn't play all the time so he said I
hope you'll vote red I hope you'll
support me and I hope you don't take
offense that I'm gonna get going and he
just left and I thought it was actually
really like nice and human and decent I
don't know if he made any money that
night I don't know if his campaign
people weren't thrilled but he's been
through the ringer right the guys run
for president Trump banged him up pretty
badly when he did that you may remember
that but Trump's endorsing him now and
he won by a landslide here in Florida
tonight and Rhonda Sanders is now up by
19 points he owes me I am getting the
tomahawk from Governor that said I wish
we had it on video I'm telling you I
swear to God guys I said to Governor
DeSantis on June 2nd I said you are
going to win this game by 15 points he
laughed like you know when he does that
really loud laugh he said no no six or
seven six or seven it looks like 19
points and you know what it could get
wider because that's widening right now
we're right about 14 15. it's widening
because obviously Republicans
like to vote in person we like the
system we want to strengthen the system
so now that the mail and balance are
getting out of the way the early voting
is getting out of the way or the mail
amounts whatever but the early voting
Republicans like they are voting so just
absolutely awesome absolutely awesome
Rennie says oh something's no
Byron Donald
all right so congressman
uh uh should we why don't we try to get
me out of the way for a moment all right
here's what we're gonna do guys I'm
gonna get out of the way so you can hear
Congressman Byron Donald's I think he
may be bringing the governor on if the
audio is absolutely terrible I may just
come back for a second then we'll cut
the feet again we're doing this on the
Fly we just we just felt like trying
something a little bit different I thank
you guys for bearing with us uh but let
the congressman take it away and uh one
one way or another I think I'll be back
in some form or another throughout the
evening thanks for watching everybody
God bless America God bless the free
state of Florida and enjoy the rest of
your evening everybody
[Applause]
no I don't even answer the speech all I
said was so good
[Applause]
you know I went through a lot of space
in the last two years
I will have been there for someone to do
better
Massachusetts Mitchell Illinois in North
Carolina and Georgia in Texas
that are right away was coming to the
United States of America
forum
[Applause]
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
Secretary of State Foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the top of the food chain
[Music]
is a guy who four years ago was duly
elected Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
either
on the sentence
and he is now being crowned by men this
is off he's now being grounded by me and
the man who knows how to set Charlie's
Prince into permanent retirement
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the Lord did that you have told the rest
of the country they are sick and tired
of democrat leadership and they're
building up three levels
he told us out of willing to keep their
lockdowns in New York
you told us allow that player they could
keep kids out of classroom in Chicago
that was his wife
I-75 or I-95 is to land in Miami
International foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
I understand just kept our businesses
open and he's to be Rewards
and
children of all ages and every other
children went around and roll midnight
they've been getting all kinds
of medicine one of the place right now
you know you know a couple of moments
now trust me
it's so very very few moment
I'm talking about
few moments
you are going to renew the thing that
the rest of America has been waiting
here
you are going to cheer
for the newly re-elected
Democrat being Freedom standing for
another discoveries
[Applause]
of America
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so much
[Music]
problems
let me take this off let me see what
kind of this is this is Davey County I
don't know what to remember what
happened two years ago and the
presidential election was a good winner
of American picked up about 12 14 000
votes total raw here we are 11 000 five
the people around Florida so that's out
there let me come back out here with
monuments and let me do let us shoot you
did not work you're going to be looking
forward
that's one thing that's pretty
interesting about North Carolina
judge in North Carolina one thing that's
really happened in these cities though
is the amount of people who have moved
into Raleigh and Charlotte and that
whole area there that has changed that
population a lot we were talking about
how many people want New England New
York from Florida and then that might
change something there North Carolina I
don't know this time around but there's
different counties that kellyanne
mentioned in those urban areas that
wants to launch of North Carolina
a little bit more each other just
remember if even this is
noticing you're sitting here or go down
there and virtually all of the employee
Builders is going to be the mailing
balance because they support processes
will be coming in and down some early
have you seen this before Tom Jones is
about how many different races one by
you know a small number of them several
hundreds of thousands of those because
the light coasters
[Music]
uh
results
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in Colorado
Democratic Center of my bed he needs at
this point
who is a local business owner an
independent type uh Republican and have
a good chance to take that same board we
can rejects that they are not available
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Republicans again holding those seats in
Florida they're looking at Ohio
Pennsylvania North Carolina but they're
looking to pick that seats and not what
was his death
[Music]
so let's take a look at this again
[Music]
at this point against
tomorrow
so we will see
[Applause]
um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and Company foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
government has a right to put these
people out of work
so
[Music]
whoever retired but your family can if I
had my brothers you know you'd take them
and you'd Chuck them across them for
time
[Applause]
and you don't care about the cost I
don't care what corporate being I would
say I don't care what Hollywood says I
don't care what a big corporations say
here I stand I'm not backing down we are
going to destroy this torch of
freedom.org and his army [ __ ] is very
simple we are keeping the State of
Florida free thank you
attention Governor Ron DeSantis
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know over these past four years
we've seen major challenges for the
people of our state for the citizens of
the United States and above all for the
cause of Freedom we saw freedom
[Music]
you know many other jurisdictions in
this country Wither on the vine
Florida held the LIE
he chose you back sober field we chose
education over indoctrination
we chose Law and Order over rioting and
disorder
was a refuge of Sanity when the world
went back we stood as the Citadel of
freedom for people across this country
and indeed across the world
we Face the tax we took that hit
the weather distorts but we stood around
we did not back down we had the
conviction to guide us and we had the
courage to leave breathe
his promises to the people of Florida
and we have delivered
after four years the people have
delivered their verdict freedom is here
to sit
thank you
[Music]
overwhelming support of the people of
Florida
[Music]
thank you for honoring us with the win
for the ages
is
[Music]
the volunteers who work so hard to get
it out the road your support means in
the world
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
agencies these folks who worked hard to
implement our agenda they believed in
our agenda and the results have been
historic thank you for your support
[Applause]
thank you to Miami Dade County
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
Beach County
[Applause]
lane from the boats but it's clearly
apparent that it was like this election
we will have garnered a significant
number of votes from people who may not
have voted for me four years ago and I
just want to let you know I am honored
to have earned your trust and your
support
[Applause]
foreign
thank you to the greatest first lady and
all 50 states
for being a great fight giving away
friends support being a tremendous
mother to our three young children and
who sermon as an example for women
throughout this state especially going
through the Battle of cancer
Shannon is
foreign
I think maybe I'm on with the blaze guys
today is the combination of the two
collections yeah it's gonna be it's
gonna be a little tricky to hear you
guys but I'm gonna do my best
and the results of that behavior has
been just as starred as our Landslide
Victory today states and cities governed
by leftist politicians have signed
Skyrocket they've seen their taxpayers
abuse they've seen medical
authoritarianism imposed and they've
seen American principles discarded the
woke agenda has caused billions of
Americans to lead these jurisdictions
for greater pastures
about this great Exodus of Americans for
those folks in Florida for so many of
them has served as the promised land
[Applause]
we have embraced Freedom we have
maintained Law and Order we have
protected the rights of parents we have
respected are taxpayers and we reject
the woke well I can talk to the camera
right now while we're waiting right
all right guys so I'm I'm waiting I
can't hear anything I'm supposed to be
jumping on with the blaze guys in a
minute the crowd's going nuts behind us
the governor the governor is talking I
hate to be talking while the governor is
talking but we're trying to jump
jump out of the governor
whoops
our policies work here's what we're
going to do here since I can't here
because it's so loud you'll just give me
a thumbs up when the blaze guys throw to
me and I'll just I'll just say hi to
Glenn and everybody and see what happens
it's going to be hard to hear anybody uh
I hope you're appreciating the alternate
version at the different angle that
you're getting here seeing this a little
bit differently than normal a little
hard I got a voice in this year I got
the governor in that ear there's a lot
going on but it's it's a big part of
your people obviously feeling great
about things and it's also great I
should say it's great to see the first
lady out there Casey just had this
obviously her cancer in full remission
and incredible recovery by her and then
to be out and about is just absolutely
awesome I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna be quiet for a moment so
you can hear the governor and then I'll
hopefully be able to hear the police
folks when they chime in
we offer
they still lie ahead I am proud of our
achievements in this state I am honored
by your support and I look forward to
the road ahead I have fought a good
fight I have finished the race and this
first Circle
that's right
even even
more than anybody thought possible four
years ago but we've got so much more to
do and I have only begun to fight God
bless you all
right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
that's my planes audio track for those
of you watching at home I'm gonna jump
onto a Glenn and the blaze guys in just
just a moment then I'll finish up solo
here man it's pandemonium here like this
is this is pure joy in this room right
now
sweet Florida indeed
wow
wow that's a good man that's a good
family all right all right I'm gonna get
ready in a minute
Daphne you just give me a thumbs up
if it's Gardener here
[Music]
[Music]
okay
thanks across the Saints goes I believe
it's good today here in the free state
[Music]
all right I think I'm on with am I on
with the blaze guys am I with the blaze
guys Glenn I don't think I'm gonna be
able to hear you
it is absolute pandemonium here is uh
Governor DeSantis just left the stage
about 20 seconds ago with the first lady
and his kids Glenn I gotta tell you and
I wish I could hear you and hopefully my
guys maybe they can tell me what you're
saying on the iPad it is so loud in here
people people are so appreciative of
being free all right I'll shake your
hands okay
it's just absolute joy in here Florida
has done it right this is the blueprint
for America it's why I left California
and why I moved to the Free State uh it
sort of feels like the culmination of
all of the things that I've been talking
about for years have taken root here all
the things that you've been talking
about way before me uh and the joy of
the fight it's here I you know I hope
the rest of the night
continues to go well for Republicans but
no matter what happens here on out we we
have a Beacon of Hope and I think that's
what maybe we've all needed more than
anything else and Glenn if you want to
chime in I'll try to have my guys type
it out so that I can read it at least I
can see you but I don't know Hi how are
you I love you too all right good to see
you man
all right Phoenix will type it out if
you uh yeah Glenn you can go ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
he's shooting my strange
[Applause]
[Music]
okay we tried it with the blaze Glenn I
hope you could hear something I was
saying uh on that note guys uh I know
this was a little messy but I've enjoyed
every moment of it I hope you have too I
hope you got to see things from a little
bit of a different perspective and uh
and really just how cool how cool I live
in California less than a year ago less
than a year ago Hi how are you
and uh and it's just such goodness here
and let's see how the rest of the night
goes but even if you're living in a
place that isn't having great results
although foreign
Freedom it might be in between Florida
or maybe it's in Tennessee or Texas or
whatever it might be uh I love that I
love this country I love this state I
love you guys thanks for watching hi uh
thank you guys and uh you know what way
out to the music for a couple minutes
and uh
have a great night everybody God bless
America God bless you guys and
that's it for now we're back in studio
tomorrow see ya